[Music]
after watching descendants two too many
times we can't stop thinking about what
is going to happen in the third movie if
there is even one today we'll hear what
the director the cast members and the
fans think we'll see in descendants
three make sure you stay tuned until the
end to know more about the dream cast
the director wants to see if you love
descendants as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you ten rumors about descendent
3 you need to hear the ending of
descendants 2 we all remember the ending
of the first descendants movie the kids
of the most terrifying villains have the
chance to go to Oregon with an evil plan
they learn the fiend cut made them feel
better and they even had to face their
parents in a final battle and just when
we thought that everyone was going to
live happily ever after now looks at the
audience with her green eyes and said
you didn't think it was the end of this
story did you as we all know it led to a
second movie in 2017 which made every
Disney fans very happy this time mal was
tired of being the good girl and decided
to go back to the Isle of the Lost
Ben wanted to save her but he ended up
being kidnapped by uma so she was the
one who had to save him everything was
fine at the end for our favorite
villains but uma decided to run away
from her happily ever after and she
surprised everyone when she said you
didn't think it was the end of the story
did you just like mouth it at the end of
the first movie does that mean that we
are going to see a third movie we hope
that it means that we are going to watch
descendants three really soon hey guys
we are so excited to announce we're
producing our
original content head over to the trendy
for the best DIYs fashion tips makeup
hacks and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section she left me
here from you see you there
the secret cliffhanger we were really
surprised to hear Emma saying that it
was not the end of the story in the
second Descendants movie but did you
know who was even more surprised it was
the actress herself china anne mcclain
that's because the last line wasn't in
the script and the wink wasn't there
either no we knew that she was going to
look at the camera to say the same line
that mal said at the end of the first
movie her eyes couldn't turn green so
she just added a little wink instead to
tease the future of The Descendants
series her co-stars Cameron Boyce Sophia
Carson and booboo Stewart also confirmed
that it wasn't planned but as it wasn't
in the original script we wonder if we
are really going to see a third movie or
not after all if they were sure that
they were going to make a third movie
they would have thought about that
cliffhanger while writing this script
some people might think that they added
this line because they learned that they
were going to make a third movie while
filming the second film but no one can
really be sure something makes us think
that someone just wanted the movie more
chances to come back because The
Descendants trilogy sounds way better
than just two movies Boo Boo's
expectations when the cast members found
out that uma was going to say the last
line of the movie they all thought that
there was going to be a third film this
is why they started thinking about what
was going to happen in the third movie
or at least what they wanted to do
booboo Stewart who plays Jade if our son
was the first one to speak he said that
he loved the song rotten to the core so
much that he wanted to see it again in
the third movie they say I'm troubled
they say I'm bad they say I'm evil and
that makes me glad we all remember the
lyrics to that song that was stuck in
our head for too many weeks after
watching the first movie and we would be
happy to hear it one more time
unfortunately for booboo we don't think
that this is going to happen we already
heard that song before and we would be
even happier to hear something new
however it shouldn't be impossible to
hear that song once again
do you remember Ben's version of be our
guest from Beauty and the Beast in the
first movie we were really happy to
rediscover this song so we think that it
would be nice to hear rotten to the core
once again in a whole different way
China's expectations when booboo said
that he wanted to hear rotten to the
core once again it was time for China
and McClain who plays umma to say what
she
to do in the next movie after all she is
the one who said that it was not the end
of the story so we really want to hear
more about what she has to say
uma has something on her mind and the
actress maybe knows about this
China surprised us once again when she
said that she would like her character
to stay a villain she thinks that it
would add a different element after all
there is no action if there is no
villain China would also like to see new
villains like dr. Vasily a also known as
the shadow man from The Princess and the
Frog he was really scary so we can't
wait to see what he would be up to next
in a descendents movie and we think that
it would be even better to see the kid
of this character no matter what one
thing is sure China really wants to come
back for a third movie because she feels
like Disney is her family they did such
great things for her career and she is
very grateful for that no matter what
they want they just have to give her a
call trying to believe that umas journey
isn't over and we can't wait to see what
she is going to do with this unfinished
business
Cameron's expectations the actor who
plays Carlos Cruella de Vil son was
inspired by his co-star and came up with
another theory about what he thinks will
happen in the next movie if there is
even one however he had to tell us that
this is only his expectation but he has
no idea as no one even confirmed that we
are going to see a third descendants
movie but we still think that his
opinion really matters to us so here's
what he has to say
Cameron boys really wants the parents to
come back he hopes that we will get the
chance to see them once again in the
movie and we totally agree with him but
wait he doesn't stop here he would like
Emma to come to their side and learn how
to be good too but then the barrier
would come down on the aisle all the
parents would come to Oregon and there
would be an epic clash however it might
be the last thing he does on Disney
Channel Cameron said that most actors
last for three or four years on that
channel but he's been working for them
for seven years the actor thinks that
his Disney days are probably over and he
wants to move on to something else
however as he saw that fans really loved
The Descendants 2 movie he thinks that
he would be ready for one last movie on
the Disney Channel Sofia's expectations
the last one to speak in this
conversation was Sophia Carson who plays
Evie and we couldn't wait to see what
she would add to that interesting story
the actress agreed with Cameron when he
said that Emma would come to their side
in the third movie and she explains why
after all Ursula's daughter is always
been longing to be part of the change we
know that she does think about it she
told them that she was upset that he
didn't chew
her so we know that she wanted to be
part of the lucky kids she even tricked
him into falling in love with her so she
could be his lady of the court she
didn't have the best intentions but
going to our Don was still part of her
plan she even had a doubt when people
tried to convince her that she could be
good too even though she finally made
the wrong choice if you watch the end of
the second movie you'll remember that
Prince Ben started bringing the kids to
our Don from the Isle of the Lost and
uma could be the next one the cast
members even added that they would like
to see another sword fight and we are
totally ready for it
no matter what she said that the cast
members are all interested in the third
movie all they're waiting for is the
fans to show that they want to see
descendants three two doves expectation
unfortunately dove Cameron wasn't part
of the conversation with the other cast
members but it doesn't mean that she
didn't have anything to say if one thing
is sure it is that she is going to come
back in as many movies as she can the
actor said on the red carpet that she
wants to see descendants three four five
six all of them bring it on she didn't
tell anyone what she would like to see
in the third movie but we still heard
about a little story that she made up in
her mind while filming descendants - if
it turned out to be true we would love
to see it in the third movie you
probably know that dove is dating Thomas
Doherty who plays Harry hook and people
could clearly see their chemistry on set
this is why they came up with a story to
explain why they behaved like that mal
and Harry dated back when she was on the
Isle of the lost and thought that she
would always be a bad girl she was the
baddest of the bad on the girls side and
he was the baddest of the bad on the
boys side
but then mal broke his heart he decided
to join Emma because they both hated her
it is just her theory but we would love
it to be confirmed in the third
descendants movie fans expectations and
we haven't forgotten about you fans also
talked about what they would like to see
in the third movie
some of them talked about new characters
like the villains Hades daughter Halle
Mother Gothel son Mason Sean Hughes son
Sean and Matt Mims daughter Maddy they
also talked about the heroes that they
would like to see like Alice's daughter
Ellie
Mowgli's daughter Morgan and King
Arthur's son Artie another fan added
many characters to the list like Mariana
a daughter of Queen Mirana chessy
daughter of Cheshire Cat Terrence
high-top son of Mad Hatter Maria
daughter of Megara
perdón son of Hercules Ariana daughter
of Ariel and Annie daughter of anah but
wait it doesn't stop here
we also have riders on a Red Queen Roxie
daughter of Red Queen Holly daughter of
Hades and Henry son of Hans other fans
think that descendants three will
probably premiere in 2019 and they hope
that it won't only be on their
television screens but also in movie
theaters someone else even wants all the
good and the bad characters to be locked
on the Isle of the Lost
but if you're here it's probably because
you are a fan too and we want to hear
what you think which new character would
you like to see in the third movie don't
be shy to tell us in the comment section
down below the Dreamcast descendants
director Kenny Ortega doesn't even know
what is coming next or if there is even
going to be a third movie that didn't
stop him from thinking about who he
wants to see in the third movie and this
man who's had a dream big the cast
already includes Duff Cameron Cameron
boy Sophia Carson booboo Stewart Chyna
and McClain and Mitchell hope and we
couldn't ask for more but Ortega made us
dream of amazing actors who could join
our favorite cast members Kenny Ortega
also directed High School Musical and
this is why he would like to work with
Vanessa Hudgens again but then he also
talked about Miley Cyrus as the actors
went from good girl to bad girl before
having the chance to truly be herself we
think that she would really understand
what the characters and descendants are
going through but that's not all
Ortega would also like the Jonas
Brothers to come back and be their Lost
Boys the director said that he was a fan
of many of the artists that have come
out of this channel and have gone on to
have great careers he also wants to have
the chance to work with people he never
worked with we think that it would be
totally awesome to see our favorite
stars from the new Disney Generation and
an older one if we could convince these
actors to do that it would be a dream
come true
the fans no matter what we are still
waiting for one thing to know if we are
going to see a third movie we already
know that most cast members would like
to come back once again for at least one
movie Kenny Ortega is already thinking
about an awesome dream cast so we are
pretty sure that he does want to direct
descendants three so what are we waiting
for
why can't Disney confirm that we are
going to see another movie as Sophia
Carson already said it is all up to the
fans producers wanted to see their
reaction and if they love the film there
could be a third one Ortega even
confirmed the same thing he said that
every once in a while he is thinking
about new characters but also the
characters that they already have
what is going to happen to them but he's
still admitted that none of them is
thinking about a third movie right now
they're waiting to see how the fans will
respond and you know what it means we
have to show Disney how much we love
descendants to make sure that we are
going to see another movie so make sure
you like this video and share it with
your friends to show your love if you
are a true fan who watched this video
until the end don't forget to write team
descendants in the comments and tell us
what you would like to see in the third
movie and that's it for a 10 rumor is
about descendants 3 you need to hear for
more stories like this make sure you
watch 10 Disney connections in
descendants - that will make your jaw
drop thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]